the laughs the where I bring an
important message from the future from
the awesome of the Year 2014
do not go see x-men Days of Future past
it's scrambled timeline will reduce your
brain too much my Mutant power is an
uncanny ability to detect when a
franchise's continuity is irrevocably
broken and this new x-men as might take
sense tingling like I'm about to get my
copy of giant-sized number one
autographed by Len wing this new film
attempts to knit together three distinct
excellence of franchises first the main
line x-men movies most recently the 2006
film x-men The Last Stand second the
terrible Hugh Jackman spin-off movies
about Wolverine and third it's also
somehow a sequel to the prequel film
x-men first class an origin story set in
the 1960s oh and it's loosely based on a
run of the uncanny x-men comic book that
traveled between the books then present
day of the early 1980s and the distant
dystopian future of 2013 which is now
our present we are through the
looking-glass people now I get that the
Marvel multiverse is made up of more
alternate realities than Shia LaBeouf's
Twitter feed but sorting out these
timelines is going to take a PhD with a
player-hater degree having both I might
even be up for it but my logic muscles
were already knocked out of commission
by being asked to accept that Michael
Fassbender grows up to be an McKellen
only one man could salvage this scramble
chronology it's shane carruth the
director of primer and the Truffaut of
time paradoxes future Shane please climb
into your primer box and travel back in
time to fix Days of Future past also
bring
DVD of age of Ultron we should be
extremely wary of any movie whose title
is based on a moody blues album what
prog rock song cycle would you like to
see turned into a summer blockbuster let
me know in the comments